des yvelines de valenciennes et même des
salariés de renault 300 personnes
étaient présentes à versailles en
soutien aux neuf salariés de l'usiné psa
poissy accusé par leur direction de
séquestration pour des faits remontant
au mois de février
des accusations que les syndicats cgt en
tête rejette en bloc
pour eux ce combat judiciaire est une
simple tentative d'intimidation
vous savez c'est nouveau pour nous
d'être traités comme des délinquants
comme des voyous de se faire assigner en
correctionnelle alors qu'on n'a rien
fait c'est nouveau maintenant ça ça nous
fait pas peur ça nous impressionne pas
on va pas se démoraliser pour ça au
contraire ça nous renforce
ça veut dire qu'on est des gêneurs on
est des gêneurs dans la politique de
tavares de vouloir exploiter encore plus
les travailleurs le jour même d'une
mobilisation nationale contre la
politique du gouvernement de nombreuses
personnalités politiques de gauche ont
aussi participé au rassemblement
malheureusement cette criminalisation
accrue de l'activité syndicale va de
pair on le voit bien avec l' attaque
contre les droits sociaux et des droits
syndicaux qui sont contenus dans les
ordonnances macro nous sommes toujours
rassemblés quand il s'agit effectivement
de se battre contre des attaques
qu'elle vienne du gouvernement où qu
elles viennent du patronat au moment de
l'enregistrement de ce reportage nous ne
connaissons pas les réquisitions du
procureur de la république
selon la loi les salariés encourt
jusqu'à cinq ans de prison ferme